[Music]
the ripples of an Odile brexit would
spread far but they'd start here in
Dover the busiest port in the United
Kingdom on a clear day you can see
France from the top of Dover's white
cliffs Calais is 21 miles away two ports
intrinsically linked by the channel by
history and now by brexit 120 billion
pounds worth of goods come through Dover
every year a sixth of our imports
brought through these gates and sent off
around the country for years we've taken
it for granted
but now you might wonder what happens
here if we leave Europe without a deal
well every day about 10,000 lorries that
come through the port of Dover it's a
very efficient place only takes about a
minute to go from this point and they
get off the ferry to leaving the dock
but if the heart breaks it means more
customs checks that'll mean more time
added to the process and very quickly
that could gum up the whole port and
here's the proof this is the effect of
operation stack miles of lorries being
parked on the motorways between London
and Dover and this is what happens when
you get delays no not in Dover
but in Cali now for brexit a new
contingency plan these the preparations
for operation brought a 13-mile stretch
of the m20 being converted into a lorry
park for 2,000 vehicles headed across
the channel for the British haulage
industry a No Deal Brecht said would
create unprecedented disruption there'd
be an immediate visible effect of any
border checks there would be queues
tailing back on the approach motorways
the m20 the other connecting motorways
with the m20 including possibly the m25
very substantial delays very distension
disruption and that would feel to all of
us like a really big
act on the economy and the way that
Britain has got used to working over the
last 20 or 30 years or so these lorries
are all coming into Britain on ferries
and through the Eurotunnel normally to
tight timetables much of British
business operates on the principle of
just-in-time
products arriving at their destination
at the very moment they're needed at
this food storage warehouse in Corby
they're building vast new areas to keep
frozen produce capacity here will more
than double in time for the end of March
all to help companies stockpile food Rob
Hardy is a veteran of Eurotunnel and the
ferry business
he says brexit will mean playing to a
different set of rules and that makes
disruption inevitable even if the
British government does all it can to
ease the way for lorries coming into our
ports on imports our club our rules but
exports back to the EU it's a common
sort of stereotypical response that the
French might be awkward in fact I don't
think they will be awkward they'll just
be doing what the rules are is that when
the when the vehicle appears at the
first European border point it has to be
checked completely in order to enter
Europe they not do anything wrong they
they've said publicly that they won't
operate a go slow they don't need to
there's enough to make it go slow his
advice is to be pragmatic for companies
to start preparing now the perfect storm
is brewing in that the trucks are not
able to get back out to reload to come
back in again and also European
transport companies will start to say I
can't go to England with my goods
because I don't come back so if there's
a if there's a break in that supply
caused by the delay on export
there isn't anyone to bring the
importing now that might take five or
six or ten days to manifest itself and
we need to be prepared for that in
Birmingham's wholesale market the
largest of its kind in the UK they pride
themselves on delivering fresh food any
delay causes problems that could mean
major problems purely on the basis that
if goods can't get to us and if supplies
feel that they don't want to send goods
because of queues on the border we're at
a pocket we haven't got goods to sell
and if to do goods do come here and
they're not of the condition that they
should be we have to dump a new takes it
on that is it losses at the sender it's
not a good deal in all things and that's
a fair expressed across the industry one
of Britain's biggest supermarkets
told Sky News that it feared panic
buying in the run-up to a No Deal brexit
some fresh food it said would run out
within days this isn't just about food
it's about all the things that knit our
nation together Joe worries about the
effects of brexit she's stockpiling
supplies but her focus isn't really on
food it's on health on the medicine she
needs for her daughter Nora she worries
that delays at the border could mean
that medicine she needs is delayed for
days or even weeks she suffers from
severe epilepsy as well as she's got
quad CP cerebral palsy Nora has lots of
various medicines some of them I can
work around I can get generics I can do
all sorts with or I can come up with a
solution however she has three drugs
that she has are critical and without
them she will have multiple seizures in
a day she will be blue lighter to the
hospital she could suffer from far worse
it could be catastrophic I can't switch
these drugs I can't use another brand of
these drugs in search of reassurance Joe
and Nora have come to see their
pediatrician
but they leave frustrated how do you
feel how do I feel really really really
worried and at the moment I just want an
answer I just I want to know someone has
a plan I want to know that if the worst
is going to happen if we are going to
have interrupted supplies it's not going
to affect me as a mum and I won't notice
or I get three months worth of supplies
upfront now so that I know that whatever
happens I'm okay because the
consequences of Noor and not having
epilepsy meds is absolutely terrifying
so is that reasonable could something as
fundamental as medicine really run out
this is absolutely critical that the
pharmaceutical industry maintains supply
to market the absolute worst case
scenario will be that certain products
are not available in certain markets
which might mean that patients have to
switch to an alternative product or or
something less effective British society
is a network of people infrastructure
and businesses it's complex and normally
robust but it can be brought down by
failure and by our own sense of panic
disruption to fuel supplies has
previously caused widespread panic
buying a bit of snow earlier this year
saw shops being stripped of fresh food
and then there's this this is 2018 it's
the year that people dial 999 because
KFC ran out of chicken the police are
the ones who pick up the pieces when the
system fails
now they've laid out their fears of how
a No Deal brexit could push them to
their limits and imagine what will
happen if we start seafood on medical
supply charges and we live in a liberal
democracy protest is good protest is
part of being in democracy where that
moves into disorder though to violence
that's the concern and where people
can't feed themselves potentially where
people can't get their insulin
potentially it's a real concern that
those protests might escalate into
disorder do you think you can cope at
the moment no Dom he told me the police
were considering asking for help from
the military and also said that food
shortages could result in rationing
something supermarkets say they are also
contemplating if the shelves on
perishable goods are empty because of
just in time and they can't get their
possible goods through especially if
you're not in a big city I think we need
to start considering how we manage
demand one of the things that
supermarkets might have to consider is
informal rationing so you can only have
three bottles of milk not a trolley full
of milk that sort of thing and there are
profound worries about policing in
Northern Ireland where the prospect of
renewed border controls has heightened
fears about simmering tension troubles
have always been there since then but
the Pearson I've been able to deal with
them to the point that we don't hear
about it on the mainland but I think
there is a volatility that bubbles away
and both sides are clearly passionate
about their view and I think if either
side saw their view being pushed to one
side they're being disadvantaged there's
a difficulty there a potential
difficulty that they might then express
those views negatively average you mean
trouble
quite possibly those who are preparing
for an Odile brexit often mentioned
uncertainty and anxiety Sky News has
spoken to dozens of companies trade
organizations and public bodies about an
Odile brexit all of them said the
prospect made them nervous the really
fundamental point about brexit is that
the United Kingdom is an island nation
and that creates challenges when it
comes to imports and exports so lots of
the things that we use come in our
trains or planes or of course on boats
like this one and that includes
medicines and food and car parts things
we need in a real hurry
it could be a profound change but one
that's hard to prepare for some plan
meticulously for No Deal some prefer to
ignore it but the people who are
preparing is that the percentage is
growing but it's still probably not half
and there are still companies that I see
who just say I'm not worried it's not
going to happen and I've kind of likened
it to the seven stages of grief and
there are still some people are still in
the denial phase and honestly when you
look at the seven stages of grief
because I have because I covered it on
it in a seminar is that that is the
project plan for brexit it's you've got
to go through this acceptance you go
through the denial the acceptance the
realization and the Knik and then moving
on
[Music]
most people I spoke to about planning
for an Odile brexit did not want to
speak in public for fear of being
accused of scare mongering but there is
nervousness across much of British
society a fear of the unknown and what
it will bring
and as bricks it gets nearer that
anxiety is growing
[Music]